good afternoon everyone
today we're going to be looking at
several anomalies
scp-252
scp-1356
scp-924
and scp-1686
all of these anomalies are different but
share one commonality they are all
aquatic in nature
for those of you who don't know i'm
conducting this seminar to cover shorter
anomalies that would not warrant their
own specific lecture but are still
noteworthy nonetheless
so without further ado
let's begin
item number
252
object class
save
special containment procedures
scp-252 is to be contained within a 150
meter cubed aquarium reinforced with
high tensile steel plating guards are to
be specifically trained in waterborne
combat techniques and armed with model
b74h harpoon rifles with high capacity
electrical discharge shafts the tank is
fitted with 15 remotely activated depth
charges which are to be detonated
simultaneously if a containment breach
is imminent the previous paragraph has
been stricken from the document a
breeding pair is maintained under the
direction of marine biologist doctor
personnel should not approach the
containment tank unless they have been
previously prepared for the anomalous
effects of the animals
additional specimens of scp-252 may
exist in the wild due to their
destructive capabilities capture is
deemed high priority given the
difficulties inherent in the size of
specimens termination is authorized if a
breach of secrecy is imminent the
following sentence was stricken from the
document current specimens are
considered sufficient and further
acquisitions are not a priority
containment of information regarding
encounters will consist of standard
cover story 53 drunken sailor and
administration of amnestics as necessary
description
scp-252 is a subspecies of docidicus
gigas mature specimens are noticeably
smaller than average reaching no more
than one meter in length and weighing a
maximum of 40 kilograms dissection shows
the absence of an ink sac and an
increased density of chromatophores
approximately 20 times the normal adult
average
behavior is identical in most ways to
mundane specimens except when hunting or
threatened when a member of scp-252
detects prey they exhibit aggressive
behavior and move towards the target at
maximum speed while rapidly cycling
their chromatophores this color shifting
has a hypnotic effect on prey animals
that make visual contact causing them to
cease all defensive behavior and
attempts to flee until grappled
when threatened by predator or otherwise
agitated
scp-252 rapidly metamorphs into an
unidentified aquatic life form of
extreme size with an indeterminate
physiology and extremely destructive
demeanor physical attributes in this
state are in a constant state of change
size fluctuates between 50 and 75 meters
in length with no fewer than 50 and
occasionally as many as 200 appendages
of various natures appendages shift
constantly between suckered tentacles
averaging 5 meters in length insectoid
limbs terminating in barbed pincers and
humanoid arms and legs ending in
sharpened talons details and positions
of appendages on the body also vary
randomly with the only constant being a
cluster of tentacles around the head
obscuring the mouth area it is currently
not known how this rapid growth is
achieved due to the potential for a
containment breach no research on the
matter is currently authorized the
previous paragraph was stricken from the
document
all animal life excluding other scp-252
and mundane squid species will attempt
to escape the vicinity by the most
direct route possible this fear response
can cause the targets to harm themselves
as they flee into hazardous conditions
or ram repeatedly into container walls
roughly 95 percent of subjects
encountering an enraged scp-252
develop a phobia of cephalopods it is
not known if this is an additional
anomalous effect or a normal behavioral
reaction to traumatic experiences
upon review of security footage during
containment doctor has determined that
scp-252's
metamorphosis is in fact an advanced
hallucination induced by the shifting
pattern of chromatophores these
hallucinations caused the victim to see
scp-252 as a titanic sea creature with
an excessively large number of tentacles
specific details vary greatly from
subject to subject but the hallucinatory
creature consistently presents as a
greatly exaggerated cephalopod with
tentacles clustered around the mouth
area additional appendages with talons
or pincers and the general impression
that all features are fluid and randomly
shifting subjects removed from visual
contact with scp-252 will remain
convinced that their hallucinations were
a real sea monster and will attempt to
rationalize any logical contradictions
inherent in their delusion such as a 100
meter monster swimming in a 10 meter
enclosed tank this rationalization and
the lingering phobia is thought to be a
form of post-hypnotic suggestion
subjects viewing video of agitated
scp-252
who have never been exposed directly
experience a much less severe fear
reaction and are able to perceive the
squid despite the hallucinations
subjects describe the illusory monster
as fake looking and nonsensical but
still find it moderately frightening
after a second hand exposure subjects
develop a partial immunity to the full
effects of direct exposure repeated
direct contact after inoculation by
video further lessens the effects
acclimatized subjects can develop a
complete immunity to the fear effect and
experience only the vagus awareness of
the hallucinations
addendum
scp-252 came to foundation attention
after numerous reports of sea monster
sightings by commercial fishermen off
the coast
agent secured a specimen at greater than
usual personal danger commendation for
performance above and beyond the call of
duty recommended agent allowed himself
to be exposed to scp-252's effects
during first contact initial containment
procedures were based on his reports of
the specimen's size and physical
capabilities resulting in an excessive
expenditure of resources disciplinary
action recommended pending oversight
review
item number
scp-1356
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-1356 is kept in a small box in the
storage facilities of research sector 9
unless approved for removal and
transportation
description
scp-1356 is a small bath toy resembling
one of several generic rubber duck
designs tests indicate that the object
is made of plasticized polyvinyl
chloride it is designed to emit a sharp
squeak when squeezed
when held by a human subject the object
appears to displace liquid water if a
subject holding the toy attempts to
enter a lake or pool for example they
will find that all liquid within an area
extending approximately 152.4
by 81.3 by 45.7 centimeters from the
body disappears
tests performed in a small indoor pool
revealed that the approximate volume of
water before and after exposure to
scp-1356
remained consistent however even in the
presence of a subject holding the
anomalous duck water levels were never
observed to rise this suggests that the
object displaces the liquid to an
unknown location from which it
eventually returns no unusual or foreign
substances have yet been detected in
displaced water although ph levels
indicate slight increase in acidity
as the depth of displaced water never
exceeds an average of 46 centimeters a
subject walking into a deep pool will
eventually find their feet and legs
submerged while the rest of the body
remains dry even vigorous motions and
leaps however never suffice to bring the
upper body into contact with water the
rectangular dry space seemingly shifts
to accommodate even the most abrupt
movements testing to discover the
parameters of this phenomenon as well as
potential practical uses are ongoing
see enclosed documents for updates and
results
excerpt 1
tantalus effect
objective determine parameters of dry
space
procedure
subjects of various heights instructed
to enter water with scp-1356
at depths never exceeding the subject's
shoulder height subjects encouraged to
make every effort to bring hands or face
into contact with the water surrounding
the dry space created by the object
results
so long as the subject is in standing
depth of the water the dry space will
shift in accordance with the subject's
motions appearing to create a mobile
rectangular indent in the water this
phenomena for unknown reasons does not
apply to the lower extremities in depths
exceeding 46 centimeters
when the test subject bends water
recedes rather than come into contact
with hands or upper body dry space
appears to maintain its shape and volume
as a rule if subject at sufficient depth
bends to the point of resting on hands
and knees the dry space will be covered
with water subjects report no change in
air pressure however breathability of
air is limited
the greatest depth at which this total
submersion of subject and dry space
could be achieved was approximately 1.5
meters dependent on the height of the
subject
excerpt 2
insufficient life raft
objective
determine whether dry space displacement
can be used to keep subject to float in
deep water
procedure
four subjects of sufficient strength and
flexibility instructed to carry scp-1356
into water of a depth of 2.5 meters an
attempt to draw legs up into dry space
results
all subjects reported the same results
with variable degrees of difficulty and
time elapsed before exhaustion the
following rules have now been
consistently demonstrated
1.
once subject is out of standing depth
dry area
scp-1356 creates a round subject
maintains its shape volume and
orientation at the surface of the water
2.
out of standing depth subjects
orientation inside of dry area becomes
fixed floating at waist depth subject
will now be able to submerge hands and
forearms in water below waist level but
any attempt to raise water in handfuls
is impossible
3.
attempts to reorient upper or lower body
inside dry space are exhausting but
prove fruitless in addition remaining in
this suspended state for more than 10
minutes negatively impacts the
circulation of blood to the lower body
eventually resulting in intense cramping
and faintness
excerpt 3
sinking test
objective test object's anomalous
properties when not carried or in
contact with human subject
procedure 1
scp-1356
placed in small pool
results
object does not displace any amount of
water or affect ph levels in any
significant way object floats
procedure 2
scp-1356
placed in a small pool and bombarded
with jets of water and various items
results
despite the objects pliant pvc materials
being easily damaged outside of water
when placed in any volume of water
sufficient to keep it afloat object
appears to resist all attempts to sink
or damage it bobbing but always
remaining upright or afloat
well with this object's origins in mind
these results might be a prompting to
examine the events and outcomes of
incident f 1992 more closely always
struck me as our business dr dhruva
addendum 1
prolonged exposure to scp-1356
hereafter defined as a sustained
interval approaching or exceeding two
hours in any depth of water appears to
affect the subject's skin which takes on
the prune-like texture associated with
autonomic nerve responses to prolonged
contact with water
after 2.5 hours of exposure a subject
was found to be significantly dehydrated
despite receiving fluids before exposure
to scp-1356
and sweating minimally
addendum 2
of course it seems we haven't been
testing the item's intended purpose
i'd imagine my nephew would say it works
rather well dr c
item number
scp-912
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
all specimens of scp-924 are to be kept
in separate 7-meter cubed saltwater
tanks within site-46 the water is to be
kept at a steady temperature of 1.6
degrees celsius or 35 degrees fahrenheit
all observation points are to be
constructed of reinforced glass if a
tank must be entered for reasons of
experimentation or cleaning the water is
to be heated to a temperature of 7
degrees celsius or 44.6 degrees
fahrenheit entering tanks outside of
these conditions is prohibited
each scp-924 is to be supplied with 85
kilograms of fresh meat on a monthly
basis
the capture or elimination of wild
specimens of scp-924
is to be carried out by special task
force tau-2 polar
pathfinders description
scp-924 is a species of pale humanoid
measuring approximately 2 meters or 6.5
feet in height the entities have the
appearance of a waterlogged human corpse
with the addition of several bony
antler-like growths on the head and a
set of external gills located just below
the ribcage they are capable of swimming
at speeds up to 30 kilometers per hour
and surviving at depths of up to one
kilometer scp-924 requires a
near-freezing arctic environment to
function properly and will lapse into a
state of estimation if the water around
it rises above 4 degrees celsius or 39.2
degrees fahrenheit
scp-924 is an ambush predator attacking
prey from underwater using either a hole
in the ice as an appropriate ambush
location or by simply breaking through
the ice itself
scp-924 is highly sensitive to both
smells and vibrations allowing it to
track prey from significant distances or
through the ice if the attack is
successful the target is probably
drowned by a cp-924 following this the
body will be dragged down to the ocean
floor by scp-924 for consumption
scp-924 will release drowned bodies
after one to six hours recovered bodies
show all signs of prolonged submersion
and high pressure as well as
liquefaction and consumption of internal
organs and muscles bodies will also
contain high levels of virulent bacteria
which when exposed to the human body
will break down most types of connective
and muscle tissue while leaving skin and
bones unharmed bacteria will remain
active within the body for up to two
weeks after feeding
scp-924 was first recorded as a series
of mysterious disappearances of ice
fishermen in the area around
while the species requires a below
freezing environment to function
properly as its internal activity
lessens as the temperatures around it
increases it has been known to migrate
south during the winter to find prey the
southernmost encounter with an scp-924
was approximately three miles outside
michigan
addendum
an incident on 20
while resulting in no casualties proved
that scp-924 are capable of supporting
themselves and moving outside of the
water and that the attacks on unwary
fishing vessels are possible special
task force tau-2 has revised their
protocols accordingly
item number scp-1686
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
the area encompassing scp-1686
is considered to be the extended grounds
of research site 27 and is to be closed
to civilian traffic under the cover of a
military proving ground if at any time
unauthorized persons are found within
the area of scp-1686
they are to be detained and questioned
in accordance with lawrence site
security operations protocol 52-a
the perimeter of scp-1686
is to be monitored at all times by
members of research site 27 security
staff via 120 wfov cameras installed
along the perimeter and satellite
imagery as provided by psyc dedicated
satellite 219f scans of the area are to
be made weekly by personnel using scout
vehicles on roads built for that purpose
in the event of activation of scp-1686
all facility personnel are to remain on
site following the activation period
research and recovery staff are to be
deployed within the grounds of
scp-1686 to recover any and all organic
materials produced by
scp-1686's effect these materials are to
be cataloged and examined within the
main site complex any materials found to
be of an anomalous nature are to be
retained for study and any non-anomalous
organic materials are to be incinerated
on-site
revision 9th of october 2010 in the
event that non-biological material is
produced by scp-1686
materials are to be retained for study
in accordance with extra-dimensional
object protocol 11a
description
scp-1686
is an area of land encompassing
approximately 750 kilometers squared of
county south dakota the physical
topography of the area consists
primarily of grassland plateaus and has
not been found to be of an anomalous
nature the floor and fauna of the region
have not been known to possess any
anomalous properties although animal
population levels in the area are lower
than those of the surrounding
environments the area is currently
uninhabited with the exception of
foundation personnel monitoring the
phenomenon and conducting biological
research
once every 20 to 50 days
scp-1686 will enter its active state
during this period cumulonimbus clouds
will form within scp-1686
generally encompassing around 60 percent
of the total area these clouds will
rotate in a counterclockwise direction
within scp-1682
as viewed from above and have never been
observed to exit the area of scp-1686
upon reaching a stage of development
normally associated with the production
of liquid precipitation clouds will
begin to produce by an unknown mechanism
a large number of marine organisms these
entities which consist largely of fish
and other aquatic organisms see addendum
scp-1686-1 then fall to the earth
normally it is estimated that
approximately 93 of all organisms
produced by scp-1686
are alive at the time of production
although very few have been known to
survive transit to earth organisms which
do survive transit generally expire
shortly thereafter
clouds produced within scp-1686
generally dissipate after a period of
five to six hours although they have
been known to persist for up to a week
while not in its active state
scp-1686 has not been known to exhibit
any unusual properties although remains
of precipitated organisms do persist in
the area for non-anomalous periods of
time
addendum 1686
organisms produced by
scp-1686 have been noted to possess
unusual properties and physiology not
concurrent with that of those known to
exist within earth's oceans these
organisms have included but are not
limited to
thanos albicares yellowfin tuna with
dorsal fins elongated to a length of six
meters and possessing an especially
flexible cartilaginous structure
caspio maison wagneri or casparian
lamprey of a length exceeding seven
meters
an unknown species of crustacean bearing
similarities to both nephrofitte
lobsters and conide cone snails capable
of producing a chemical which when
ingested by a human subject produces
very vivid hallucinations followed by
death by cerebral hemorrhaging within 16
hours
a specimen of coracias oretis oratus or
common goldfish featuring three extra
pairs of dorsal fins with advanced bone
and muscular structures along with a
greatly enlarged hind brain the area
generally associated with motor control
a school of upwards of 32 000 miniature
istio forest albicans or atlantic
sailfish each approximately 3
centimeters in length
and a currently unidentified species of
predatory marine organism of unknown
taxonomic classification similar in
appearance to an extremely large amanita
muscaria or fly agaric a type of
toadstool featuring a propulsion siphon
and a variety of bulb-like growths to
serve as navigational aids
addendum 1686-3
7th of july 1979 a previously unknown
species of fungus was found to have
infested a large section of grassland
within containment area believed to have
originated from an
scp-1686 produced organism evidence
indicates that it was most likely
originally found within a mucous
membrane of an unidentified
filter-feeding organism similar in
appearance to scylerinidae or cat sharks
infestation grew to cover an area of
approximately three kilometers squared
within a period of 23 hours during an
extended downpour containment teams were
successful in destruction of infestation
after several attempts samples of fungus
have been retained for study
addendum 1686 4
the 6th of may 1986 a large increase in
the proportion of celecomorpha or sharks
produced by
scp-1686 as compared to other groups has
been reported organisms show
abnormalities similar to those present
in previously recovered specimens within
a special propensity towards increased
size
addendum 1686-7
the 12th of october 1997 first recorded
instance of mammalian organism produced
by scp-1686
organism found to be genetically similar
to balina mistacetus or bowhead whale
following cleanup extensive damage done
to portion of research facility as a
result of collision cover story issued
to in-range radar towers regarding
testing of experimental targeting
systems on large targets to account for
radar contact all future developments of
research site 27 are to be situated
underground and current main facility is
to be relocated accordingly
addendum 1686-10
10th of september 2010 a large
approximately 30 meters in length
presumably ocean-going vessel was
observed to fall from cumulonimbus
clouds formed within scp-1686
the vessel was largely destroyed by
impact but video and forensic evidence
indicates that its structure was not
congruent with that used by any known
culture within historical record sabels
recovered also indicate that the
materials used to construct the vessel
thought to be a kind of extremely dense
fungal structure did not match any known
materials the addition of increased
shielding to site facilities has been
recommended and is currently in progress
as of the 12th of september 2010.
previously
under review
i would like to give a special thank you
to
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
jaby
pure osmium
sayo dio demnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbich
kawaii fire keeper
longinus
king madding
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you